réunie et Sébastien Desrosiers
les a rencontrés.
- Allô!tre au Canada avec papa?
- Happy!
- La famille estnie.
- De pouvoir venir! Rody est alr
sa femme et ses enfants
à la frontiè.
- Nous vivons dans un Québec
de la place pour tout le monde.
- Arrivé à Montréal en 2017,
il n'ava
JEAN RODY LAINE
- C'était époustouflant.
Parce que la petite Coralie,
elle m'a regardé dans les yeux.
"Est-ce que c'est toi, Rody?"
ESTHER LAINE
- Je suis libérée,
je peux voir ma
séparés alors qu'elle était
enceinte il y a près de cinq
ans. Ils disent avoir échappé
(sonnerie de télrie de télrie d)
- Oui, allô?
- Esther n'avait
Elle a trouvé refuge au Chili.
Nous lui avions paaine
dernière. Après avoir traversé
le continent pour rejoindre son
mari,
- C'était vraiment difficile.
- Elle s'est d'abord présentée
au poste de Lasé l'entrée au Ca.
Elle n'a eu d'auque
d'emprunter le chemin Roxham.
Le chemin est rouvert depuis
de trois semaines.
Déjà, des centaines de personnes
sont passées par là.
BQ en matière d'immigration
- C'est pas tous les gens qui
n habillés, c'est pas
tous les gens qui sont au fait
de comment on traverse
ce chemin-làtaire. Il taire. Ils
là-dedans la plupart du temps.
- Le Bois a remis
une lettre au ministre
de l'Immigration pour lui
demandd'Esther. Il pourrait y ar
eu erreur quand elle a été
refoulée la première fois.
Elle venait après tout rejoindre
Ce refus fait en sorteaujourd'ht
est incertain.o. qué.,o. qué.,o,
avocats, droit de l'immigration
- Elle va être demandeud'asile,a
possibilité d'obtenir un permis
de travail et d'avoir les soins
sa demande d'asile étudiée.
elle fera une demande
de résidence permanentepour dpo.
JEAN RODY LAINE
- Avoir la résidet donner en ree
la société m'a donnée.
famille a famille a famille a g
chemin à parcourir, un cas
qui illustre à quel point
la réunification familiale
- J'aurais aimé que
le gouvernement facilite
le regroupement
peu imace,
la couleur et l'originepas faci.
- Mais ils avancent,
un pas à la fois et profitent
de chaque instant. Ici S Ici S ,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.